[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es einen fünf minuten kuchen
ich habe nämlich lust auf kochen
bekommen und deswegen wird der gebacken
ich habe hier einen teig der richtig
einfach ist und auch so eine art
grundrezept und damit könnt ihr wirklich
apfelkuchen backen zwetschgenkuchen
birnen kuchen was auch immer ihr wollt
alles was schnell gehen soll ich zeige
euch mal kurz die zutaten ich verwende
dafür eine limette die ist unbehandelt
so dass ich die schale und auch den saft
verzehren kann 2 100 gramm zucker etwas
vanille extrakt eine prise salz 80 gramm
joghurt es und dreieinhalb prozentiger
40 gramm milch 80 gramm soll um 200
gramm back mehr da ist backpulver schon
mit drin und 50 gramm gehobelte mandeln
jetzt fehlen nur noch die äpfel und sie
holt dich schnell draußen im garten mit
[Musik]
das sind so tolle denn die sind nicht
nur außen sondern auch innen rot dem so
ein ganz tolles buch fleisch und davon
nehme ich jetzt so so dass irgendwer 4
standard äpfel haben kleine paar große
und die schneide ich jetzt einfach
den und die schneide ich jetzt einfach
in spalten
jetzt einfach das kerngehäuse einmal
entfernen und dann einfach schön kleinen
stücken
[Musik]
ich habe auch noch eingehender
apfelsorte die eigenen apfelsorte heißt
edel mehr
und haben auch im apfelbaum im garten
stehen da habe ich jetzt noch nicht
gedruckt es zweifel gibt aber die sind
auch außen rot und rosa ja aber die
roten die sind schon schon wahnsinnig
cool
emirat der name kommt von ella unter
mehr
und das und das lvm und da schreibt man
groß elmar heißt nämlich auf türkisch ja
das ist unsere apfelsorte
unterkomplex jedes jahr immer neue app
und ganz viele von euch haben den baum
schon
okay jetzt
mal einfach so große spalten also echt
gar nicht so klein würfeln das gebe ich
dann auch direkt eine backform ich hole
die meisten
und da gehe es ist einfach schon am bug
transfer ein
bisschen
[Musik]
dann kommt da jetzt de limettenschale
rein und da einfach nur darauf achten
dass die eben nicht gespritzt ist und
zum verzehr geeignet ist
so ein bisschen
anstand den saft dazu geben weil ich
doch da reicht jetzt bei mir tatsächlich
hälfte denn meine äpfel sind säuerlich
die brauchen nicht so viel soll
dann ist der teil schon vorbereitet und
jetzt geht's an den teig der ofen ist
auch schon vorgeheizt auf 180 grad ober
unterhitze und den teig werde ich jetzt
echt einfach im mixer zu bereiten ihr
könnt auch ein handrührgerät nehmen oder
anderen schneebesen alles verrühren und
dann kann ich jetzt hier die eier
reingeben
dann den zucker
ein bisschen ganz
süßen gerichten bin ich schon sparsam
mit salz und
wann ihr extrakt und
da zutaten mix ich einmal kurz schaumig
durch
[Musik]
und jetzt gebt ihr einfach alle anderen
zutaten auch dazu
ein all-in-one teig richtig einfach und
da kann man nichts machen
ich benutze tatsächlich ganz gerne wenn
es mal schnell gehen muss dann wenn ich
ein rührkuchen macht mit butter du musst
die butter immer erst mal weich werden
und bei öl hat man einfach den vorteil
das kann man einfach direkt immer dazu
geben da gewinnt dann auch nichts unter
passiert nix dann das bak mail das
regelt immer so schön und da ist einfach
das perfekte verhältnis von backpulver
schon mit dabei
und das klingt dann auch nicht zwingen
sich dies nicht 7
und die mandeln die kommen obendrauf das
heißt hier habe ich jetzt alles drin und
joghurt habe ich drin
und fertig und jetzt nur noch ganz kurz
mixen bis sich alles vermischt hat denn
sobald mail in den teig dazu kommt jetzt
einfach nur wichtig nicht mehr lange zu
rühren damit der kuchen eben trotzdem
schön locker wird und nicht so fest wird
[Musik]
und dann gießt ihr den teig über die
äpfel drüber gut mal so sollte die
kompetenz von
[Musik]
der wird bestimmt auch richtig gut vom
grill also wenn ihr echtes geld und ihr
habt alles was herzhaft ist durch dann
bereitet einfach diesen kuchen zu dann
stellte er noch mit auf dem grill
ja das ist ein guter grill kuchen
hier noch ein bisschen verteilen aber
das muss gar nicht so arg dass verteilt
sich sowieso gleich im backofen dann
noch die mandeln drüberstreuen und dann
kann er gewaschen werden das war
[Musik]
so wird der kuchen ist so richtig schön
und ich streu da jetzt müssen schnell
drauf das ist ein futter zucker der
nicht schmilzt auch wenn es gebäck
fertig oder warm ist und dann sehe ich
das ganze gleich ich guck mal ob ich eis
da hat wenn ich nämlich naturjoghurt
sahne joghurt das passt auch gut dazu
oder geschlagene sahne das ist auch gut
aber trägt erstmals sarah den kuchen zum
kaffee
[Musik]
so das war echt ein blitzschnelles
rezept und das darf heute der max
probieren
ja du hast was du gemacht
wir schreiben jetzt auf die kamera
kamera kennt mag sie weil ich die ganze
zeit dabei war okay aber ging schnell
oder das ist sehr sehr schwer damit ja
fast schon mal kuchen gebacken ja aber
noch nicht aus dem nichts sagen ich
denke jetzt tobias maus comics aus ich
habe ja keinen draht zu hause aber der
verstaubten also kein kuchen keine musik
keine schecks
ja aber nicht aus um mixa ja ich mache
tatsächlich waffen nämlich auch im mixer
und das geht viel schneller als mit
einem handrührgerät und macht keine
keine klümpchen
okay kommt probier mal ob es geschmeckt
ich habe noch naturjoghurt den den
sahnejoghurt und stichfesten okay es mag
sich ist ein anderes wort sogar kuchen
ich habe dass ich nur ein apfel auch im
krieg und jetzt denn so ein bisschen
säuerlich aber die sind nicht schlecht
das wirklich gesagt alles auf die gabel
krieg geht auf ein bisschen zu sauer
ist luftig sehr luftig und ich rate auch
dann wenn die äpfel noch so ein bisschen
kosten
sind ist leicht säuerliche finde ich gut
ach so ja ja ich weiß nicht was du hast
es ist gut dass krebs jutta hat den
abriss erfolges nektar ist auch schon
sauber aber auch höheren passt es ja
echt immer ganz gut ist gut jetzt haben
wir nur noch keinen titel für den kuchen
weil ich für fünf minuten apfelkuchen
klingt so langweilig dass der idee habt
dann schreibt sie gerne in die
kommentare
und vielleicht schreibt er mir auch was
ein absolutes
lieblings april perfekt ist ich hoffe es
ist von mir
hoffe ich bestimmt oder 100 prozent was
ist dein lieblings apfelkuchen rezept
fünf minuten mit rezept
also viel spaß beim nachhaken bis zum
nächsten mal
und ihr könnt übrigens falls sie dieses
grundrezept verwendet den mixer kuchen
nenne ich denn jetzt mal ihr könnt auch
ein schock draus machen indem wir
einfach ein bisschen kakaopulver dazu
gibt
es jetzt statt gedacht mir habe kommt
den teilweise mit allen teams
[Musik]